bonjour irin gilberte docteur en
physique des particules
j'en avais partout des pieds à la tête
même dans les plis et sa part pas comme
ça nous avons consacré nos vies avec des
phénomènes paranormaux
et voilà que les cas se multiplient un
peu partout les gens ont besoin de nous
on nous réclame
gilliane tué ingénieurs de très haut
niveau erin en physique quantique
personne n'arrive à la cheville
je vais toujours ça je m'inscris au club
je connais bien new york bienvenus
bonjour c'est pour le poste d'agent
d'accueil
oui c'est un cachet
c'est par ces partis voulaient une fois
cet hôpital à la prochaine chose à
quelqu'un est en train de mettre au
point un amplificateur de phénomènes
paranormaux
il faut qu'on invente quelque chose pour
affronter ces satanés pour tous
partis qui s'occupent de leur quête moi
je m'entends balcon
alors là je sais pas si c'est du racisme
ou de la misogynie
mais je suis en pétard ça y est
j'ai demandé à kevin de nous proposer
quelques idées de logo pour notre code o
j'ai peur que ce soit pas très bon pour
notre image si ce sont les saints qui ne
conviennent pas je peux les faire plus
gros